- Willkommen bei „Understanding
Quantum Information and Computation".
Mein Name ist John Watrous, und ich bin der technische Direktor
von IBM Quantum Education.
Der Zweck dieser Reihe ist es, dir ein
solides Verständnis von Quanteninformation und -berechnung zu vermitteln, was bedeutet, in die
technischen Details einzutauchen
der Quanteninformation und zu verstehen, wie Quantencomputing
wirklich funktioniert, was es kann und was nicht.
Falls du das Übersichtsvideo
zu dieser Reihe noch nicht gesehen hast, empfehle ich dir, es dir anzuschauen.
In diesem Video findest du Informationen darüber, welche Vorkenntnisse
für diese Reihe empfohlen werden, sowie einen Überblick über
die behandelten Themen.
Schau dir außerdem unbedingt
das Qiskit-Lehrbuch an, das dasselbe
Material wie diese Videoreihe in schriftlicher Form abdeckt,
und das auch interaktive
Komponenten sowie Schnittstellen zu Hardware und Software enthält, die dir helfen sollen, besser zu verstehen,
wie Quanteninformation und -berechnung funktionieren. Links zum Übersichtsvideo und zum Qiskit-Lehrbuch
findest du in der Beschreibung.
Dies ist Lektion eins von
Einheit eins der Reihe.
Einheit eins behandelt die Grundlagen
der Quanteninformation, und in der ersten Lektion dieser Einheit konzentrieren wir uns darauf, wie
Quanteninformation funktioniert
für einzelne Systeme, das heißt, wir haben
nur ein physikalisches System oder ein Gerät irgendeiner Art, das Quanteninformation speichert
und wir betrachten, wie dieses
eine System oder Gerät isoliert funktioniert.
In der nächsten Lektion werden wir besprechen, wie
Quanteninformation funktioniert, wenn wir mehrere Systeme haben, und das wird es uns ermöglichen,
interessante
und wichtige Konzepte zu beschreiben, wie z. B. Quantenalgorithmen, die mehrere qubits verwenden,
und Quantenprotokolle,
an denen mehrere Personen beteiligt sind, die Quanteninformation verarbeiten und sie gegenseitig hin und
her übertragen.
Aber bevor wir in diese Diskussionen einsteigen, macht es Sinn, mit dem
vergleichsweise einfachen Fall eines einzelnen Systems in Isolation zu beginnen,
teils weil es gut ist, einfach anzufangen, aber auch weil, wie wir sehen werden, die Beschreibung davon, wie
Quanteninformation funktioniert,
für einzelne Systeme in Isolation sehr natürlich und logisch zur Beschreibung führt, wie
Quanteninformation funktioniert
für mehrere Systeme.
Hier ist ein kurzer Überblick über die Lektion.
Wir beginnen mit einer Diskussion über
klassische Information.
Der Zweck dieser Lektion ist es nicht, zu erklären, wie
klassische Information funktioniert, sondern zu erklären, wie
Quanteninformation funktioniert,
aber um zu erklären, wie
Quanteninformation funktioniert, ist es sehr hilfreich, mit
klassischer Information zu beginnen und sie als
vertrauten Ausgangspunkt zu verwenden,
wenn wir Quanteninformation besprechen.
Auf mathematischer Ebene haben Quanten- und klassische Information tatsächlich recht ähnliche Beschreibungen, mit einigen wesentlichen Unterschieden natürlich.
Tatsächlich ist Quanteninformation
gar nicht wirklich von klassischer Information getrennt.
Sie ist eine Erweiterung von
klassischer Information.
Die Tatsache ist,
zumindest aus meiner Sicht, dass man Quanteninformation wirklich nicht
verstehen kann, wenn man klassische Information nicht versteht,
daher macht es Sinn, mit klassischer
Information zu beginnen.
Ich erwarte, dass dieser
Inhalt einigen Zuschauern vertraut sein wird, aber selbst wenn du damit vertraut bist, empfehle ich dir nicht, ihn zu überspringen.
Neben der Hervorhebung der Aspekte klassischer Information, die für das
Verständnis von Quanteninformation am relevantesten sind, werden wir in diesem Teil die
Dirac-Notation einführen,
die eine Standardmethode ist,
mit der wir Vektoren und
Matrizen in der gesamten Reihe beschreiben werden.
Wie sich herausstellt, ist die Dirac-Notation nicht
spezifisch für Quanteninformation.
Sie kann gleichermaßen im Kontext klassischer Information sowie in vielen anderen Bereichen verwendet werden, in denen Vektoren und Matrizen vorkommen.
Wir gehen dann zur Quanteninformation über, und konkret werden wir
die Darstellung von Quantenzuständen als Vektoren besprechen,
einen einfachen Typ von Messung, die sogenannte Standardbasismessung, und unitäre Operationen, die diskrete zeitliche
Veränderungen in Quantensystemen beschreiben.
Wieder alles im Rahmen von
einzelnen Systemen.
Bevor wir mit der Lektion selbst beginnen, ist es hilfreich klarzustellen, dass es tatsächlich zwei Beschreibungen gibt
der Quanteninformation: die vereinfachte Beschreibung, auf die wir uns in dieser Lektion konzentrieren werden,
und in der gesamten ersten Einheit, und die allgemeine Beschreibung, die in einer späteren Einheit behandelt wird, konkret in der
dritten Einheit der Reihe.
Die vereinfachte Beschreibung ist,
ihrem Namen entsprechend, einfacher und wird
typischerweise zuerst gelernt.
In der vereinfachten Beschreibung werden, wie ich bereits angedeutet habe, Quantenzustände durch Vektoren dargestellt und Operationen durch
unitäre Matrizen.
Diese Beschreibung der Quanteninformation reicht aus, um
die meisten Quantenalgorithmen zu verstehen, zum Beispiel,
sie ist also nicht übermäßig vereinfacht, sondern die echte Sache.
Allerdings werden wir,
wie wir im Laufe der Zeit entdecken werden, feststellen, dass sie einige Einschränkungen hat.
Wenn wir zum Beispiel
die Auswirkungen von Rauschen auf Quantensysteme modellieren wollen, erweist sich diese Beschreibung als unzureichend.
Die allgemeine Beschreibung hingegen ist allgemeiner und letztendlich
mathematisch gesehen mächtiger.
In dieser Beschreibung werden Quantenzustände durch eine spezielle Klasse von Matrizen
dargestellt, die Dichtematrizen genannt werden,
und eine allgemeinere Klasse von
Messungen und Operationen kann beschrieben werden, einschließlich
Rauschen zum Beispiel.
Sie ist vollständig konsistent mit
der vereinfachten Beschreibung, und tatsächlich kannst du die vereinfachte Beschreibung
im Wesentlichen als
Spezialfall der
allgemeinen Beschreibung betrachten, und sie schließt auch klassische Information als Spezialfall ein.
Es ist auch wirklich ziemlich
schön, wie alles zusammenwirkt, deshalb empfehle ich dir sehr, diese allgemeine Beschreibung kennenzulernen,
wenn die Zeit gekommen ist, aber die vereinfachte Beschreibung ist der natürlichere Ausgangspunkt, und deshalb werden wir damit beginnen.
Wir werden damit beginnen, über klassische Information zu sprechen, mit Blick auf die Aspekte
klassischer Information, die für
Quanteninformation am relevantesten sind,
und die Art, wie sie
mathematisch beschrieben wird.
Stell dir vor, wir haben ein
physikalisches System oder ein Gerät irgendeiner Art, das Information speichert.
Wir werden diesem System den Namen X geben, aber an diesem Namen
ist nichts Besonderes.
Wir könnten jeden anderen
Namen verwenden, wenn wir wollten, aber nur um einen Namen zu wählen,
werden wir das System X nennen.
Wir werden eine Annahme über X machen, nämlich dass es eine
endliche Menge klassischer Zustände gibt, in denen sich X zu jedem
gegebenen Zeitpunkt befinden kann.
Wenn ich hier von einem klassischen Zustand spreche, meine ich eine Konfiguration des Systems, die eindeutig erkannt und
beschrieben werden kann,
ohne jegliche Unsicherheit oder Fehler.
Das ist wirklich etwas, worüber du intuitiv nachdenken kannst. Auf mathematischer Ebene definieren wir einfach die
Menge der klassischen Zustände,
wir wählen sie so, wie wir es wollen oder in der Weise, die das Gerät, mit dem wir arbeiten, am besten
beschreibt.
Lass uns der
Menge der klassischen Zustände den Namen Sigma geben, und nochmals möchte ich betonen,
dass wir davon ausgehen, dass Sigma eine endliche Menge ist.
Die Menge der klassischen
Zustände dieses Systems X ist nicht unendlich groß wie
die Menge aller natürlichen Zahlen.
Sie ist endlich, und das ist einfach eine
Annahme, die wir treffen.
Zum Beispiel könnte es sein, dass X ein Bit ist, in welchem Fall die klassische Zustandsmenge die Menge mit zwei
Elementen ist: null und eins.
Manchmal bezeichnen wir diese
Menge als das binäre Alphabet.
Ein weiteres Beispiel ist, dass X ein
gewöhnlicher sechsseitiger Würfel ist, in welchem Fall die klassischen Zustände die Zahlen eins bis sechs sind.
Natürlich sprechen wir hier
über eine Abstraktion.
Ein echter sechsseitiger Würfel kann
viele verschiedene Eigenschaften haben, wie seine genaue
Position, seine Ausrichtung,
seine Temperatur und so weiter. Aber in Bezug auf die Information, die am häufigsten relevant ist, wenn wir über einen sechsseitigen Würfel sprechen,
sind die klassischen Zustände
die Zahlen eins bis sechs, angegeben durch die Anzahl der Punkte auf der nach oben zeigenden Seite des Würfels.
Wenn X ein Schalter an einem
handelsüblichen Ventilator ist, wie man ihn zu Hause haben könnte, dann sind die klassischen Zustände vielleicht
die Einstellungen hoch,
mittel, niedrig und aus.
Das sind nur Beispiele. Wir könnten uns Systeme mit anderen klassischen
Zustandsmengen vorstellen, aber hoffentlich vermitteln sie die Idee.
Dieses Konzept eines klassischen Zustands ist etwas, das
vertraut sein sollte und in einfachen und intuitiven Begriffen verstanden werden kann.
Mathematisch gesehen ist die Menge der klassischen Zustände
einfach eine endliche Menge, und natürlich muss diese Menge
auch nicht leer sein.
Es muss mindestens
einen klassischen Zustand geben, in dem sich das System befinden kann, und es müssen mindestens zwei klassische Zustände vorhanden sein,
damit das System überhaupt für die Speicherung von Information nützlich ist.
In manchen Situationen wissen wir vielleicht, dass sich X in einem
bestimmten Zustand befindet, aber in vielen Situationen,
die im Kontext der
Informationsverarbeitung auftreten, kann es Unsicherheit über den klassischen Zustand eines
Systems zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt geben,
so dass jedem möglichen klassischen Zustand eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit zugeordnet ist.
Wenn X zum Beispiel ein Bit ist, dann ist es vielleicht so, dass sich X im klassischen Zustand null befindet
mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von drei Viertel, und es befindet sich im Zustand eins
mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von einem Viertel.
Wir werden das als einen
probabilistischen Zustand bezeichnen, und wir könnten
diesen probabilistischen Zustand, wie du hier siehst, ausdrücken,
indem wir einfach angeben,
wie die Wahrscheinlichkeiten für die verschiedenen klassischen Zustände sind.
Eine kompaktere Möglichkeit, diesen
probabilistischen Zustand auszudrücken, ist durch einen Vektor, insbesondere die Darstellung,
die du hier siehst,
ist ein Spaltenvektor, und dieser Vektor gibt an,
wie die Wahrscheinlichkeiten für die beiden möglichen klassischen Zustände sind.
Genauer gesagt gibt der erste Eintrag an,
wie hoch die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist, dass sich X im Zustand null befindet, und der zweite Eintrag sagt uns,
wie hoch die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist,
dass sich das System im Zustand eins befindet. Das ist einfach die natürliche Reihenfolge des binären Alphabets,
oder zumindest ist es die Weise, wie
wir darauf trainiert wurden, dies zu tun. Mit null zuerst und eins als zweitem.
Zukünftig werden wir den
Begriff Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor verwenden, um einen solchen Vektor zu bezeichnen.
Konkret ist es ein Vektor, dessen Einträge alle
nicht-negative reelle Zahlen sind und bei dem die Summe der
Einträge gleich eins ist,
es macht also Sinn, diese Einträge
als Wahrscheinlichkeiten zu betrachten.
In diesem Beispiel gibt es nur zwei Einträge, weil es nur zwei
klassische Zustände des Systems gibt, über das wir sprechen,
aber im Allgemeinen könnte es
beliebig viele Einträge geben, wobei zu verstehen ist,
dass es einen Eintrag für jeden klassischen Zustand gibt
des Systems, über das wir gerade sprechen.
Wir werden gleich noch weiter
über klassische Information, Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektoren und
so weiter sprechen, aber zunächst wird es sehr hilfreich sein,
eine Notation einzuführen,
um Vektoren zu beschreiben, die als Dirac-Notation bekannt ist.
Das ist tatsächlich nur der erste
Teil der Dirac-Notation.
Es gibt noch einige andere
Aspekte der Dirac-Notation, die wir etwas
später in der Lektion kennenlernen werden.
Diese Notation wird
sehr zentral für die Art und Weise sein, wie wir Quanteninformation beschreiben, daher ist es wichtig zu
verstehen, wie sie funktioniert,
aber glücklicherweise ist sie sehr einfach und hat eigentlich
nichts speziell mit Quanteninformation zu tun,
daher können wir sie jetzt
im vertrauten Kontext der klassischen Information einführen.
Wie zuvor nehmen wir an, dass wir eine Menge Sigma von
klassischen Zuständen eines Systems haben, und gehen davon aus,
dass wir eine Ordnung
dieser klassischen Zustände haben, ähnlich wie wir auf eine
Ordnung des binären Alphabets verweisen
im vorherigen Beispiel. Anders ausgedrückt
werden die Elemente von Sigma in Entsprechung
mit den ganzen Zahlen gebracht
von eins bis zu der Anzahl der
Elemente in Sigma, was diese Notation hier mit den zwei Balken um Sigma bedeutet.
Das ist die Anzahl der
Elemente in der Menge Sigma.
Es gibt also einen ersten Zustand,
einen zweiten Zustand, und so weiter.
Die spezifische Ordnung oder
Entsprechung, die wir wählen, wird eigentlich nicht so sehr darauf ankommen.
Was wirklich wichtig ist,
ist, dass wir eine Ordnung haben und dabei bleiben.
Für viele klassische Zustandsmengen,
denen wir begegnen werden, wird es eine Standardordnung geben, genau wie wir sie beim
binären Alphabet haben,
und falls es keine Standardordnung gibt, können wir einfach eine wählen.
Aber was auch immer es ist, es gilt: Wir bleiben dabei.
Nun, hier ist die Notation,
die eingeführt wird.
Für jede Wahl eines klassischen
Zustands a aus unserer Menge Sigma schreiben wir das hier, was als Ket a
gelesen wird und den Spaltenvektor bedeutet,
der eine Eins im Eintrag entsprechend a und eine Null für alle anderen Einträge hat.
Zum Beispiel, wenn wir
zum binären Alphabet zurückkehren, was, wie du vielleicht erraten hast, ein sehr wichtiges Beispiel ist,
zu dem wir immer wieder zurückkehren werden. Dann sind Ket Null und Ket Eins die Vektoren, die hier definiert sind.
Ket Null ist der Vektor,
der eine Eins im Eintrag entsprechend dem klassischen Zustand Null hat, also im ersten Eintrag,
und eine Null für alle anderen Einträge, und in diesem Fall gibt es
nur einen weiteren Eintrag.
Entsprechend ist Ket Eins
dieser Vektor hier, bei dem wir eine Eins im
Eintrag entsprechend Eins haben,
also im zweiten Eintrag, und eine Null für alle anderen Einträge, was wieder nur ein Eintrag ist.
Hier ist ein weiteres Beispiel. In diesem Beispiel haben wir eine
klassische Zustandsmenge Sigma, die den vier Farben
in einem Standardkartenspiel entspricht: Kreuz, Karo, Herz und Pik.
In diesem Fall gibt es keine
allgemein anerkannte Ordnung dieser Farben.
Bei vielen Kartenspielen gibt es überhaupt keine Ordnung. Es sind einfach vier verschiedene Farben und das ist alles, was zählt, und es gibt verschiedene Kartenspiele,
die diese Farben ordnen
auf verschiedene Weisen, aber das spielt keine große Rolle.
Wir können einfach eine
Ordnung wählen, wie die, die du hier siehst.
Dies ist zufällig die alphabetische Ordnung entsprechend den englischen Namen dieser vier Farben,
Angenommen, wir haben
diese bestimmte Ordnung gewählt, dann definieren wir diese vier Vektoren: Ket clubs, Ket diamonds,
Ket hearts und Ket spades
wie du es hier siehst, und diese Vektoren entsprechen
der allgemeinen Beschreibung, die du oben siehst.
Da wir
diese bestimmte Ordnung für diese vier Farben gewählt haben.
Wir können dasselbe für jede klassische Zustandsmenge tun,
die wir wählen.
Dabei gilt zu beachten, dass eine klassische
Zustandsmenge immer eine endliche und nicht leere Menge bedeutet.
Vektoren dieser Form werden
Standardbasisvektoren genannt, und es ist eine sehr grundlegende Tatsache über Vektoren, dass jeder Vektor auf eindeutige Weise ausgedrückt werden kann
als Linearkombination
von Standardbasisvektoren.
Zum Beispiel, um auf das Beispiel von vorhin zurückzukommen, lässt sich der Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor,
den wir gesehen haben, ausdrücken
wie du es hier siehst. Es ist im Grunde nur eine alternative Art, Vektoren auszudrücken,
die aus verschiedenen Gründen sehr praktisch sein wird.
Und mit dieser Notation nun in unseren Händen wollen wir zur Diskussion
über klassische Information und insbesondere probabilistische Zustände zurückkehren.
Und lass uns überlegen, was passiert,
wenn wir ein System messen, während es sich in einem probabilistischen Zustand befindet.
Normalerweise würden wir
vielleicht nicht von einer Messung oder dem Akt des Messens
von etwas in einem klassischen Kontext sprechen, aber der Begriff macht Sinn.
Im Wesentlichen meinen wir,
wenn wir davon sprechen, das System X in diesem Kontext zu messen, nur, dass wir es betrachten und erkennen, in welchem Zustand es sich befindet.
Natürlich sehen wir beim Betrachten des Systems keinen probabilistischen Zustand, sondern einen klassischen Zustand,
und der bestimmte
klassische Zustand, den wir sehen, ist einer, von dem wir
uns vorstellen können, dass er gemäß den Wahrscheinlichkeiten zufällig ausgewählt wird.
Nun könntest du aus
philosophischen Gründen der Idee widersprechen, dass der klassische Zustand, den wir sehen, irgendwie zufällig ausgewählt wird
in dem Moment, in dem wir messen oder das System betrachten, war das System von Anfang an einfach in einem bestimmten
klassischen Zustand
und wir haben nur zufällig
erfahren, in welchem Zustand es war, aber um über den mathematischen
Rahmen nachzudenken, mit dem wir arbeiten,
ist es in Ordnung, es so zu betrachten, und dies wird uns ermöglichen, etwas später eine Parallele zur
Quanteninformation zu ziehen.
Angenommen, der
klassische Zustand, den wir sehen, ist der klassische Zustand a, der jeder Zustand in unserem Satz sigma sein könnte.
Dies verändert im Allgemeinen den probabilistischen
Zustand von X, zumindest aus unserer Perspektive.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeiten haben
keine Bedeutung mehr, da wir jetzt wissen, was
der klassische Zustand von X ist.
Es ist a, und es gibt
keine Unsicherheit mehr darüber.
Wir würden jetzt also sagen,
dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sich das System im Zustand a befindet, eins ist.
Wir wissen dies, weil wir es gerade betrachtet haben und gesehen haben, dass der klassische Zustand a ist, also ist der neue probabilistische Zustand von X eins
bei dem die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
im klassischen Zustand a zu sein, gleich eins ist.
Und dieser probabilistische Zustand wird durch den
Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor Ket a dargestellt.
Wir haben eine Eins im Eintrag, der dem klassischen Zustand a entspricht, und eine Null in allen anderen Einträgen.
Wenn wir zum Beispiel wieder
die Situation betrachten, in der X ein Bit ist und wir denselben
probabilistischen Zustand wie zuvor haben,
dann können wir uns beim Messen von X vorstellen, dass ein
Übergang stattfindet.
Mit Wahrscheinlichkeit drei Viertel sehen wir den klassischen Zustand null, und durch die Messung wechseln wir zu Ket null
als unseren probabilistischen Zustand,
und mit Wahrscheinlichkeit ein Viertel wechseln wir zu Ket eins.
Du kannst dir das als einen Wissenswechsel vorstellen, wenn du möchtest, im Gegensatz zu einem tatsächlichen
physischen Übergang,
aber was für diese Lektion
wichtig ist, ist zu erkennen, wie die Mathematik funktioniert.
Es ist eigentlich ziemlich trivial, aber indem wir diese Trivialität erkennen, erscheint die analoge Beschreibung
für den Quantenbereich
vielleicht etwas weniger mysteriös.
Eine letzte Anmerkung ist, dass für eine andere Person, die nicht zufällig gesehen hat, in welchem
klassischen Zustand X war, als wir ihn gemessen haben,
sich der probabilistische Zustand
natürlich nicht dadurch ändern würde, dass wir ihn gemessen haben.
Das ist in Ordnung. Verschiedene Personen können
unterschiedliche Kenntnisse über ein bestimmtes System haben und entsprechend
unterschiedliche probabilistische Zustände wählen,
um ihr
Wissen über dieses System darzustellen.
Im letzten Teil dieser Diskussion über klassische Information sprechen wir über klassische Operationen, die an einem System durchgeführt werden können,
beginnend mit deterministischen Operationen.
Wenn wir eine Operation an einem System durchführen, ändert sich sein Zustand im Allgemeinen dadurch, und in diesem Kontext bedeutet das Wort deterministisch,
dass das Ergebnis der Durchführung
der Operation vollständig von dem klassischen
Zustand abhängt, in dem sich das System befand,
bevor die Operation durchgeführt wurde.
Mit anderen Worten gibt es
kein Zufallselement, wenn eine deterministische
Operation durchgeführt wird, also keine Zufälligkeit
oder Unsicherheit.
In mathematischen Begriffen werden deterministische Operationen
durch Funktionen beschrieben.
Jede Funktion f der Form,
die du hier siehst, was bedeutet, dass sowohl die Eingabe als auch die Ausgabe der Funktion
Elementen unseres
klassischen Zustandssatzes sigma entsprechen, beschreibt eine deterministische Operation.
Der klassische Zustand a wird
für jede Wahl eines Zustands a in den Zustand f von a umgewandelt.
Für jede Funktion f dieser Form wird es immer eine eindeutige Matrix M geben, die diese Bedingung erfüllt,
die du hier siehst,
und zwar, dass durch Multiplizieren
von M mit dem Vektor Ket a der Vektor Ket f von a ergibt,
und das gilt für jede
Wahl eines klassischen Zustands a.
Es ist nicht allzu schwer, eine
explizite Beschreibung von M zu formulieren, gegeben welche Funktion f
dieser Form wir gewählt haben.
Sie wird immer genau
eine Eins in jeder Spalte haben, wobei jeder andere Eintrag gleich null ist.
Und hier ist die Formel: Der b, a-Eintrag von M ist gleich eins, wenn b gleich f von a ist,
und ansonsten ist er gleich null, und damit meinen wir,
dass dies der Eintrag von M ist, dessen Zeile b entspricht
und dessen Spalte a entspricht.
Wir werden gleich ein paar Beispiele sehen und verstehen, warum diese Formel funktioniert.
Nun ist es vielleicht nicht klar, warum wir eine Funktion nehmen und sie als Matrix ausdrücken möchten,
aber es macht Sinn, dies zu tun. Einer der Gründe, und vielleicht ist es der Hauptgrund, ist, dass wenn wir ein System
in einem probabilistischen Zustand haben
und wir führen eine deterministische
Operation an diesem System durch, dann lässt sich der resultierende probabilistische
Zustand berechnen
durch Matrix-Vektor-Multiplikation, d. h., wenn unser System sich
in einem probabilistischen Zustand befindet
der durch einen
Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor v dargestellt wird und wir die deterministische
Operation ausführen, die durch M beschrieben wird,
dann ist der resultierende probabilistische Zustand durch M mal v gegeben.
Übrigens ist dieser Pfeil mit
einem kleinen Balken darunter nur eine übliche mathematische Notation, die anzeigt, wie eine
Sache abgebildet wird auf
oder in eine andere Sache umgewandelt wird. Du könntest auch einfach einen normalen Pfeil verwenden, aber das ist die Konvention
und ist erkennbar, und vielleicht ist es etwas spezifischer als nur ein Pfeil, der viele verschiedene Dinge bedeuten könnte.
Schauen wir uns jetzt ein Beispiel an – genauer gesagt eine Reihe von Beispielen.
Betrachten wir, was passiert, wenn wir unsere klassische Zustandsmenge sigma wieder als das binäre Alphabet wählen.
Wenn dies unsere klassische Zustandsmenge ist, gibt es nicht allzu viele verschiedene Funktionen der Form, über die wir gesprochen haben – genauer gesagt gibt es genau vier
Funktionen dieser Form.
Diese vier Funktionen werden hier durch ihre sogenannten Wertetabellen beschrieben.
Die erste Tabelle beschreibt
die erste Funktion, die wir f1 genannt haben.
Für jeden möglichen Eingabewert auf der linken Seite listen wir den entsprechenden
Ausgabewert auf der rechten Seite auf, also ist f1 von null gleich null,
und f1 von eins ist ebenfalls gleich null – das bedeutet, dass f1
die konstante Nullfunktion ist.
Sie nimmt immer den Wert null an.
Die zweite Funktion f2
ist die Identitätsfunktion.
Der Ausgabewert ist immer gleich dem Eingabewert, wie du in der zweiten Tabelle sehen kannst.
Die dritte Funktion f3 wird
durch die dritte Tabelle beschrieben.
f3 von null ist gleich eins, und f3 von eins ist gleich null.
Diese Funktion ist besser
bekannt als die NOT-Funktion oder logische Negation.
Manchmal nennen wir sie auch Bit-Flip, weil sie null
zu eins und eins zu null umkehrt.
Die letzte Funktion f4 ist
ebenfalls eine konstante Funktion wie die erste, aber diese ist die konstante Einsfunktion
weil sie immer den Wert eins annimmt.
Und das sind die einzigen vier Funktionen vom binären Alphabet auf sich selbst.
Hier sind die vier Matrizen, die diesen vier Funktionen entsprechen und durch
die Formel von vorhin beschrieben werden,
die du hier siehst, und wenn du magst, kannst du das Video pausieren und das überprüfen.
Denk dabei daran, dass bei Matrizen die Reihenfolge der Indizes immer zuerst Zeilen, dann Spalten ist.
Der Eintrag b, a entspricht
also Zeile b und Spalte a, also der Zeile, die dem
klassischen Zustand b entspricht,
und der Spalte, die dem
klassischen Zustand a entspricht.
Wenn wir zum Beispiel
die erste Funktion betrachten, haben wir f1 von null gleich null
und entsprechend ist der
Eintrag null, null von M1 gleich eins.
Der Eintrag eins, null,
der hier ist, ist gleich null, und dasselbe kannst du für den Fall machen,
dass der Eingabewert gleich eins ist, und entsprechend für die
anderen drei Funktionen.
Du kannst auch überprüfen, dass diese
Formel von vorhin gilt, indem du alle verschiedenen
Möglichkeiten einzeln durchgehst.
Und wenn du dir überlegst, wie
Matrixmultiplikation funktioniert, kannst du das eigentlich schon auf den ersten Blick erkennen.
Wenn du eine Matrix mit einem Standardbasisvektor multiplizierst, kannst du dir vorstellen, dass du den
Eingabewert nimmst
und ihn oben in eine der Matrizen
in der Spalte fallen lässt, die dem klassischen Zustand entspricht,
der im Ket steht, und der Ausgabewert, den du
erhältst, ist einfach diese Spalte als Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor.
So ergibt zum Beispiel M3 multipliziert mit Ket
null den Wert null, eins
als Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor, was Ket eins ist.
M3 multipliziert mit Ket
eins ergibt eins, null, was Ket null ist, und so weiter.
Wir werden Operationen auf
probabilistischen Zuständen gleich noch genauer besprechen, aber zunächst wollen wir den zweiten Teil der Dirac-Notation einführen.
Das wird hilfreich sein,
um über Operationen zu sprechen und sie als Matrizen zu betrachten, und es wird auch ein Standardwerkzeug sein
das wir weiterhin verwenden werden. Die Grundlage ist genau wie zuvor.
Wir haben eine beliebige klassische Zustandsmenge sigma, mit der wir arbeiten, und wir nehmen an, dass wir eine Möglichkeit haben, diese klassischen Zustände zu ordnen.
Wir schreiben dann dieses
Ding hier, bei dem diesmal
der Winkelstrich links statt rechts steht, um den Zeilenvektor zu bezeichnen, der eine eins hat
in dem Eintrag, der
a entspricht, und eine null bei allen anderen Einträgen, die den anderen
klassischen Zuständen entsprechen.
Der Unterschied zwischen
diesem Ding und Ket a ist also, dass dies ein Zeilenvektor und
Ket a ein Spaltenvektor ist,
ansonsten sind die Vektoren
jedoch ähnlich definiert.
Wir lesen das als Bra a – ich bin nicht sicher, ob das lustig sein soll, aber die Idee ist, dass die Begriffe Bra und Ket
die zwei Hälften des Wortes Bracket sind, und darüber werden wir gleich noch mehr sagen.
Aber zuerst schauen wir uns
ein ganz schnelles Beispiel an.
Für das binäre Alphabet gilt, dass bra null dieser
Zeilenvektor hier ist, analog zu ket a,
außer dass es ein Zeilenvektor ist
statt eines Spaltenvektors, und bra eins ist dieser Vektor hier.
Wenn wir nun im Allgemeinen einen Zeilen-
vektor mit einem Spaltenvektor multiplizieren – betrachten wir diese einfach als Matrizen,
die zufällig nur
eine Zeile oder nur eine Spalte haben –, dann erhalten wir eine Ein-mal-Eins-Matrix, die wir uns
als Skalar vorstellen können.
Die Sterne hier solltest du dir
übrigens als beliebige Zahlen vorstellen.
Wenn wir insbesondere den Zeilenvektor bra a
mit dem Spaltenvektor ket b multiplizieren,
dann können zwei Dinge eintreten.
Entweder sind a und b gleich – sie befinden sich also im selben klassischen Zustand –, in welchem Fall die Einsen übereinander liegen
und das Produkt gleich eins ist, oder es könnte der Fall sein,
dass a und b verschieden sind,
die Einsen also nicht übereinanderliegen und das Produkt gleich null ist.
Eine einfache Art, diese
Beobachtungen auszudrücken, ist so wie hier.
Und nur um es übersichtlich zu halten, schreiben wir dieses Produkt so mit nur einem Strich in der Mitte, und es bedeutet genau dasselbe
wie das hier.
Jetzt siehst du, wie bra und ket zusammenpassen
und eine Klammer bilden, die auch
inneres Produkt genannt wird,
was etwas recht Wichtiges ist,
auf das wir in
Lektion Nummer drei zurückkommen werden.
Einen Spaltenvektor hingegen mit einem Zeilenvektor
zu multiplizieren ergibt eine Matrix, wie du hier sehen kannst.
Gehen wir also zum Beispiel noch einmal
zurück zum binären Alphabet: Wenn wir ket null mit bra null multiplizieren,
erhalten wir diese Matrix hier, und wir können die
anderen Möglichkeiten durchgehen, um zu sehen, was passiert.
Ket null mal bra eins ergibt
diese Matrix hier, wobei die Eins jetzt an
diese Position gewandert ist.
Ket eins, bra null sieht so aus und hier ist ket eins, bra eins.
Was wir dabei sehen, ist, dass es in einer Matrix, die sonst überall null ist, genau eine einzelne Eins gibt, und die Position dieser Eins
wird davon bestimmt, welche
klassischen Zustände wir in bra und ket wählen.
Genauer gesagt – und das gilt im Allgemeinen für jede Wahl einer klassischen Zustandsmenge – ist die Matrix, die wir durch
Multiplizieren von ket a mit bra b erhalten,
die Matrix mit einer Eins im Eintrag a, b und einer Null für alle anderen Einträge.
Und jetzt, da wir sowohl den
ersten als auch den zweiten Teil der Dirac-Notation haben, verfügen wir über ein sehr praktisches Werkzeug, um Operationen mit Matrizen zu verbinden.
Gehen wir also kurz zurück
zu deterministischen Operationen und erinnern uns daran, dass etwas
früher in der Lektion
gesagt wurde, dass für jede Funktion f
der Form hier eine deterministische Operation existiert, die a in f von a transformiert
für jeden möglichen klassischen Zustand a. Und wir haben gesagt, dass es für
jede solche Funktion immer eine eindeutige
Matrix M gibt, die so wirkt
auf Standardbasisvektoren.
Mit der Dirac-Notation können wir diese Matrix jetzt ganz einfach ausdrücken, wie du hier siehst,
und wir sehen, wie es manchmal
möglich ist, mit Matrizen vollständig
im Rahmen der Dirac-Notation zu arbeiten,
ohne jemals explizit in
Vektoren und Matrizen, also Rechtecke gefüllt mit Zahlen, umzurechnen.
In diesem Fall können wir überprüfen, dass die
gewünschte Formel gilt, indem wir M mit ket a multiplizieren.
Wir setzen unseren
Ausdruck für M so ein und können die Klammern entfernen und bra
b mit ket a so zusammenfügen.
Das liegt daran, dass die Matrizenmultiplikation
linear ist, in diesem Fall im ersten Argument, und assoziativ, sodass wir die Klammern entfernen können.
Und wenn wir uns nun erinnern, dass wir ein festes a haben, über das wir sprechen, während wir über alle
möglichen Wahlen von b summieren,
ist diese Klammer hier
immer gleich null, wenn b nicht gleich a ist, sodass es keinen
Beitrag zur Summe gibt,
und wenn b gleich a ist, ist die Klammer gleich eins, und so bleiben wir mit
diesem einen Term hier übrig.
Das ist die Formel, die wir wollten, und so haben wir eine sehr elegante und einfache Möglichkeit, eine Funktion als Matrix auszudrücken.
Zusätzlich zu deterministischen Operationen haben wir auch Operationen, die
selbst Zufälligkeit oder Ungewissheit über den
klassischen Zustand eines Systems einführen.
Wir verwenden den Begriff probabilistische Operation für solche Operationen, und genau genommen meinen wir mit probabilistischer Operation,
Operationen, die möglicherweise Zufälligkeit einführen, sodass deterministische Operationen eigentlich ein Sonderfall
von probabilistischen Operationen sind,
die zufällig keine
Zufälligkeit einführen.
Hier ist ein einfaches Beispiel, bei dem
etwas Zufälligkeit eingeführt wird.
Das ist eine Operation auf einem einzelnen Bit. Sie funktioniert so: Wenn der klassische Zustand
des Bits eine Null ist,
passiert nichts. Das Bit bleibt eine Null. Aber wenn der klassische
Zustand des Bits eine Eins ist, dann kippt die Operation das Bit zu null
mit Wahrscheinlichkeit 1/2.
Diese Operation hat keinen besonderen Namen,
zumindest nicht, der mir bekannt wäre.
Es ist nur ein Beispiel, aber du könntest dir vorstellen, diese Operation
auf einem Bit auszuführen.
Genau wie deterministische Operationen können probabilistische Operationen
durch Matrizen dargestellt werden, und ihre Wirkung auf probabilistische Zustände
wird durch Matrix-Vektor-Multiplikation beschrieben, genau wie zuvor.
Diesmal muss es nicht unbedingt der Fall sein, dass die Matrizen genau eine Eins in jeder Spalte haben und sonst Nullen.
Probabilistische Operationen werden
allgemeiner durch stochastische Matrizen dargestellt.
Das sind Matrizen, deren Einträge alle
nicht-negative reelle Zahlen sind und bei denen die Einträge in
jeder Spalte eins ergeben.
Das ist gleichbedeutend damit zu sagen,
dass stochastische Matrizen Matrizen sind, bei denen jede Spalte
einen Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor bildet.
Das macht Sinn, wenn du dir die
Wirkung einer Matrix auf einen Standardbasisvektor vorstellst.
Du nimmst einen beliebigen
klassischen Zustand und stellst dir vor, diesen Zustand oben in die Matrix in die Spalte einzusetzen, die
diesem klassischen Zustand entspricht,
und diese Spalte sagt dir,
welcher probabilistische Zustand als Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor herauskommt.
Die probabilistische Operation
in unserem Beispiel wird zum Beispiel durch diese Matrix hier beschrieben.
Wenn wir diese Operation
auf den klassischen Zustand null anwenden, dann wird der probabilistische Zustand, den wir erhalten, durch die erste Spalte gegeben,
was wieder der klassische Zustand null ist, oder gleichwertig, der probabilistische
Zustand, bei dem null mit Wahrscheinlichkeit eins auftritt.
Wenn wir stattdessen diese Operation auf den klassischen Zustand eins anwenden, dann randomisieren wir das Bit im Wesentlichen und entsprechend erhalten wir
diesen Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor hier,
bei dem die Wahrscheinlichkeit für
jeden der möglichen Zustände gleich 1/2 ist.
Im Allgemeinen, wenn wir diese Operation auf einen beliebigen probabilistischen Zustand anwenden, dann ist der Effekt im Wesentlichen
ein gewichteter Durchschnitt zwischen den zwei Spalten,
weil das so funktioniert, wie eine Matrix-Vektor-
Multiplikation funktioniert.
Sie ist linear, also mitteln wir einfach die beiden
möglichen Ergebnisse entsprechend.
Wenn wir über probabilistische
Operationen auf diese Weise nachdenken, liegt es nahe, sie als
möglicherweise einführende oder injizierende Zufälligkeit zu betrachten.
Wir können einfach die Spalten eine nach der anderen lesen und sehen die Zufälligkeit,
die sie für jeden möglichen klassischen Zustand einführen.
Du kannst probabilistische Operationen
auch auf eine etwas andere Weise betrachten, nämlich dass sie zufällige Auswahlen deterministischer Operationen sind.
In unserem Beispiel können wir zum Beispiel diese Operation als äquivalent betrachten zu
dem Werfen einer fairen Münze,
und entweder die
konstante Null-Funktion oder die Identitätsfunktion auszuführen,
jeweils mit Wahrscheinlichkeit 1/2,
und du kannst das hier
genau in dieser Gleichung sehen.
Das ist immer möglich für
jede probabilistische Operation, und es ist ziemlich intuitiv.
Wenn du zufällige Entscheidungen
als Teil eines Prozesses getroffen hast, könntest du dir immer vorstellen, diese zufälligen Entscheidungen im Voraus zu treffen,
und diese Entscheidungen dann
fest in eine Sammlung von deterministischen Operationen einzuprogrammieren.
Es ist manchmal sehr hilfreich, über probabilistische
Operationen auf diese Weise nachzudenken, und wir werden ein Beispiel
dafür in ein paar Lektionen sehen.
Das Letzte, was
über klassische Information für diese Lektion zu sagen ist, betrifft das Zusammensetzen
probabilistischer Operationen, was einfach bedeutet, eine nach der anderen auszuführen.
Nehmen wir an, wir haben
ein System namens X und M1 bis Mn sind stochastische Matrizen, die probabilistische
Operationen auf X darstellen.
Stell dir zunächst vor, dass wir
einen Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor v haben, der einen probabilistischen
Zustand von X zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt darstellt, und dann wenden wir zunächst
die erste probabilistische Operation auf X an, die durch die Matrix M1 dargestellt wird, und dann wenden wir die zweite
probabilistische Operation an,
die durch M2 dargestellt wird.
Wenn wir das tun, dann ist der
Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor, den wir nach dem Anwenden nur der ersten
Operation erhalten, M1 mal v,
und wenn wir dann
die zweite Operation anwenden, ist der resultierende Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor M2 multipliziert mit dem Vektor, den wir erhalten haben,
nachdem wir M1 angewendet haben. Es sieht also so aus.
Nun ist die Matrizenmultiplikation
eine assoziative Operation, was bedeutet, dass es keine Rolle spielt, wo wir diese Klammern setzen.
Wir könnten die Klammern also genauso gut
so setzen.
Das ist sehr einfach, aber auch interessant, weil es zeigt, dass wir
über die Operation nachdenken können, bei der wir zuerst M1 anwenden,
und dann M2 anwenden,
als eine einzelne Operation.
Mit anderen Worten, die
probabilistische Operation, die wir durch das Zusammensetzen der ersten und
zweiten probabilistischen Operation erhalten, wird durch das
Matrizenprodukt M2 mal M1 dargestellt,
und das ist dieselbe Operation unabhängig davon, mit welchem probabilistischen
Zustand wir begonnen haben.
Wir müssen nichts über den Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor v wissen, um über
diese zusammengesetzte Operation nachzudenken oder sie zu beschreiben.
Beachte, dass die Reihenfolge
hier M2 auf der linken Seite und M1 auf der rechten Seite ist, weil die
Matrix auf der rechten Seite, M1,
diejenige ist, die
mit dem Vektor v multipliziert wird, während M2 mit dem Vektor multipliziert wird,
den wir nach der Multiplikation mit M1 erhalten.
Wir müssen also immer im Hinterkopf behalten, dass sich die Reihenfolge in gewissem
Sinne umkehrt.
Die zuerst ausgeführte
Operation ist die auf der rechten Seite, und die Operation, die zuletzt ausgeführt wird, in diesem Fall als zweite,
ist die auf der linken Seite.
Wenn wir nicht bei der zweiten Operation aufhören und alle der Reihe nach anwenden, beginnend mit der ersten und endend mit der letzten, die Mn ist,
dann ist die Zusammensetzung all
dieser Operationen durch dieses Produkt gegeben,
das du hier siehst,
und du siehst, dass die Reihenfolge
wieder aus genau demselben Grund wie zuvor umgekehrt ist.
Kurz gesagt: Zusammensetzungen
probabilistischer Operationen werden durch Produkte
stochastischer Matrizen dargestellt, die sie repräsentieren.
Dabei ist zu beachten, dass dies
die Reihenfolge der Matrizen im Produkt ist.
Du erhältst immer eine stochastische Matrix, wenn du ein Produkt
stochastischer Matrizen wie dieses bildest, und manchmal drücken wir diese Tatsache
damit aus, dass die stochastischen
Matrizen unter der Multiplikation abgeschlossen sind, und du kannst
dir das so vorstellen, dass du nicht aus der
Menge der stochastischen Matrizen herauskommst,
indem du sie multiplizierst, weil die Menge abgeschlossen ist.
Um auf die
Reihenfolge der Matrizen in diesem Produkt zurückzukommen: Es ist wichtig zu beachten, dass die
Reihenfolge wirklich wichtig ist.
Matrizenmultiplikation ist nicht kommutativ. Wenn du die Reihenfolge
der Matrizen im Produkt änderst, kann sich das Ergebnis ändern,
und wir müssen nicht weiter als bis zu den deterministischen
Operationen schauen, um das zu sehen.
Hier ist ein einfaches Beispiel für
zwei stochastische Matrizen, die beide
deterministische Operationen darstellen, bei denen die Reihenfolge eine Rolle spielt.
M1 repräsentiert die konstante Nullfunktion. Angenommen, wir stellen uns vor, dass diese beiden Operationen auf Bits wirken, genau wie im Beispiel von vorhin.
M2 repräsentiert die NOT-
Operation oder einen Bit-Flip.
Wenn du zuerst M1
und dann M2 ausführst, ist das Ergebnis diese Matrix hier, die die
konstante Einsfunktion darstellt.
Wenn du ein Bit auf null setzt
und es dann umkehrst, ist das dasselbe, als würdest du
dieses Bit auf eins setzen.
Wenn du andererseits zuerst M2
und dann M1 ausführst, ist dies das Ergebnis hier,
und das ergibt Sinn, denn wenn du ein Bit umkehrst
und es dann auf null setzt, ist das dasselbe, als würdest du
es einfach auf null setzen.
Es war egal, dass du es umgekehrt hast. Diese beiden
Matrizen sind offensichtlich nicht dieselben, und so haben wir ein sehr
einfaches Beispiel, das zeigt,
dass die Reihenfolge wichtig ist. Das ist natürlich überhaupt nicht überraschend.
Wir wissen alle, dass die Reihenfolge, in der
Operationen ausgeführt werden, wichtig ist – oder zumindest wichtig sein kann.
Zum Beispiel: Wenn du ein
Streichholz anzündest und dann darauf bläst, ist das Ergebnis sehr anders,
als wenn du zuerst auf das Streichholz bläst
und es dann anzündest. An diesem Punkt haben wir sehr viel
über klassische Information gesprochen, und jetzt ist es endlich Zeit,
Quanteninformation zu besprechen.
Und was wir feststellen werden, ist, dass
mathematisch gesehen Quanteninformation
ähnlich wie klassische Information funktioniert,
mit einigen wesentlichen Unterschieden.
Der erste wesentliche Unterschied
liegt gleich am Anfang: wie wir einen Zustand definieren – in diesem Fall einen Quantenzustand eines Systems,
und es gibt einen Sinn, in dem diese eine Wahl, wie
wir einen Quantenzustand definieren, weitgehend bestimmt, wie
Quanteninformation funktioniert.
Wir werden auch definieren, wie
Messungen und Operationen funktionieren, und in der nächsten Lektion werden wir besprechen, wie
Quanteninformation nicht nur für einzelne Systeme
funktioniert, sondern für mehrere Systeme,
aber diese Dinge folgen eigentlich
ziemlich natürlich, sobald der Begriff eines Quantenzustands eines einzelnen Systems
isoliert betrachtet etabliert wurde.
Hier ist die Definition. Ein Quantenzustand eines Systems wird durch einen Spaltenvektor dargestellt, dessen Indizes
in Entsprechung zu den
klassischen Zuständen dieses Systems gesetzt werden.
Wir nehmen hier also an, dass
das System, über das wir sprechen, eine gewisse Menge klassischer Zustände hat, genau wie damals, als wir über klassische Information gesprochen haben,
und probabilistische Zustände. Die Einträge in einem Quantenzustandsvektor
sind komplexe Zahlen, im Gegensatz zum probabilistischen Fall,
wo die Einträge
nicht-negative reelle Zahlen sind.
Und diesmal muss die Summe der Betragsquadrate
der Einträge gleich eins sein, im Gegensatz zur Summe, die im probabilistischen Fall gleich eins ist.
wie wir es im probabilistischen Fall haben.
Die komplexen Zahlen, die
in einem Quantenzustandsvektor erscheinen, werden manchmal Amplituden genannt und spielen eine Rolle, die
Wahrscheinlichkeiten ähnelt,
aber sie sind keine Wahrscheinlichkeiten und haben nicht die
gleiche Interpretation.
Ich kann dir keinen guten Grund nennen, warum Quantenzustände
so definiert sein sollten, außer zu sagen, dass
Physiker entdeckt haben,
dass diese Definition
physikalisch relevant ist und es uns ermöglicht, quantenmechanische Systeme zu beschreiben und zu modellieren.
Mit anderen Worten: Wir wählen diese Definition,
weil sie funktioniert, nicht weil es
besondere Gründe gibt, warum Quantenzustände
so definiert sein sollten.
Bezüglich der
Mathematik dieses Begriffs eines Quantenzustands ist der erste Schritt zum Verstehen und Arbeiten damit,
diese Definition aufzurufen
für die euklidische Norm eines Vektors, die du geometrisch als die Länge eines Vektors betrachten kannst, genau wie du über die Länge
eines zweidimensionalen reellen Vektors nachdenken würdest, wenn du ihn auf ein Blatt Papier
als Pfeil zeichnen würdest, der auf die übliche Weise vom Ursprung ausgeht.
Konkret: Wenn wir einen
Spaltenvektor v wie diesen haben, von dem wir annehmen, dass er
komplexe Zahleneinträge hat, Alpha eins bis Alpha n,
dann ist die euklidische Norm von v so definiert, wie du es hier siehst.
Dies ist die Notation, die wir
für die euklidische Norm verwenden, indem wir diese doppelten Balken um den Vektor setzen, über den wir sprechen.
In diesem Fall ist es v, und die euklidische Norm ist so definiert, dass sie die Quadratwurzel der Summe ist.
der Quadrate der Absolutwerte
der Einträge des Vektors.
Eine andere Möglichkeit, einen
Quantenzustandsvektor zu definieren, ist: Ein Quantenzustandsvektor ist ein Spaltenvektor mit
komplexen Zahlen als Einträge,
dessen euklidische Norm gleich eins ist, das heißt, er ist ein Einheitsvektor bezüglich der euklidischen Norm.
Das liegt daran, dass die Summe der
Quadrate der Absolutwerte genau dann gleich eins ist, wenn die euklidische
Norm gleich eins ist.
Die Quadratwurzel ändert nichts, wenn die Summe der
Quadrate der Absolutwerte gleich eins ist.
Das ist also ein Quantenzustandsvektor: ein Spaltenvektor mit Indizes, die den
klassischen Zuständen eines Systems entsprechen,
mit komplexen Zahlen als Einträge und einer euklidischen Norm gleich eins.
Was das bedeutet, was es impliziert oder wie wir diesen
Begriff interpretieren sollen, ist eine andere Frage und in gewissem Sinne
ist das Studium der Quanten-
information und -berechnung eine Erkundung dessen, was
diese Definition impliziert, zumindest im Hinblick auf
Informationsverarbeitung.
Dies ist schlicht der Ausgangspunkt.
Nebenbei sei erwähnt, dass es
noch andere sogenannte Normen neben der euklidischen Norm gibt und diese Schreibweise hier
mit den doppelten Strichen
um einen Vektor herum nicht immer
die euklidische Norm bedeutet.
In verschiedenen Kontexten kann diese Schreibweise
auf eine andere Norm verweisen.
Zum Beispiel ist die Summe
der Absolutwerte ohne Quadrate oder Quadrat-
wurzel eine andere Norm,
die oft als Einsnorm bezeichnet wird. Es gibt tatsächlich eine ganze Menge
verschiedener Normen.
Manchmal siehst du,
dass diese Schreibweise mit einem Index nach
den zweiten Strichen verwendet wird, der mehr Informationen darüber gibt, welche Norm gemeint ist.
Wenn wir das tun, ist es recht üblich, dass die Zahl zwei als Index
die euklidische Norm bedeutet.
Aber in dieser Reihe gilt, wann immer wir einen
Spaltenvektor wie diesen haben, bedeutet diese Doppelstrich-Schreibweise allein
die euklidische Norm.
Hier sind einige Beispiele
für Quantenzustandsvektoren, und diese speziellen Quantenzustandsvektoren sind qubit-Zustandsvektoren,
was bedeutet, dass die
klassischen Zustände unseres Systems null und eins sind.
Das Wort qubit ist die Kurzform von Quantenbit, was im Grunde nur ein Bit ist,
das sich in einem Quantenzustand befinden kann.
Die ersten beiden Beispiele sind ganz einfach. Die Standardbasisvektoren
Ket-null und Ket-eins sind Quantenzustandsvektoren.
Beide sind Spaltenvektoren, und die Indizes entsprechen
den klassischen Zuständen null und eins, und die Einträge dieser
Vektoren sind komplexe Zahlen.
Bei diesen speziellen Vektoren sind die Einträge null und eins, also reelle Zahlen, und genau genommen sogar ganze Zahlen, aber sie sind auch komplexe Zahlen,
die zufällig einen
Imaginärteil gleich null haben.
Jeder Vektor hat einen Eintrag gleich eins und einen Eintrag gleich null.
Wenn wir also die Quadrate der Absolutwerte
der Einträge summieren, erhalten wir in beiden Fällen eins.
Die Bedingungen,
die erforderlich sind, damit diese Vektoren Quantenzustandsvektoren sind, sind also erfüllt.
Die nächsten beiden Beispiele sind sehr häufig anzutreffende qubit-Zustände, die als Plus-Zustand und Minus-Zustand bezeichnet werden.
Sie werden, wie du
hier auf dem Bildschirm siehst, entweder mit einem Ket-Plus
oder einem Ket-Minus wie folgt dargestellt, und sie sind
so definiert, wie du hier siehst.
Auch hier sind die Einträge dieser
Vektoren komplexe Zahlen. Diesmal sind sie entweder positiv eins durch Wurzel zwei oder negativ eins durch Wurzel zwei,
und wenn wir die
Quadrate der Absolutwerte summieren, erhalten wir 1/2 plus 1/2, also eins.
Übrigens mag es etwas seltsam erscheinen, ein
Plus- oder Minuszeichen in ein Ket zu setzen,
da dies keine klassischen
Zustände unseres Systems sind,
aber diese Schreibweise wird dennoch verwendet, und darauf kommen wir gleich zurück.
Kurz gesagt können wir die Dirac-Notation jedoch verwenden, um einen beliebigen Namen für einen Vektor in ein Ket zu schreiben.
Der Vektor muss kein
Standardbasisvektor sein, wenn wir die Dirac-Notation verwenden.
Hier ist ein letztes qubit-Zustands-
beispiel, zumindest für den Moment.
Es ist ein Quantenzustandsvektor eines qubit, der keinen speziellen Namen hat und nicht besonders bedeutsam ist.
Die Einträge dieses Vektors sind eins plus zwei mal i
durch drei und negativ 2/3.
Das sind komplexe Zahlen, und wenn du die
Quadrate der Absolutwerte dieser beiden Einträge berechnest, erhältst du 5/9 für den ersten
und 4/9 für den zweiten. Die Summe der
Quadrate der Absolutwerte ist also gleich eins.
Und hier ist ein letztes Beispiel. Diesmal für ein System,
dessen klassische Zustände die vier Kartensymbole sind.
Ich weiß nicht, warum wir ein System hätten, dessen klassische Zustände
die vier Kartensymbole wären und das sich in einem Quantenzustand befindet, aber es ist prinzipiell möglich,
und es ist nur als Beispiel gedacht.
Die Einträge, die
den verschiedenen Symbolen entsprechen, sind 1/2 für Kreuz, negativ
i durch zwei für Karo,
null für Herz, da es in der Summe nicht vorkommt, und eins durch Wurzel
zwei für Pik.
Und so sieht es
als Spaltenvektor aus, wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass wir
die klassischen Zustände wie zuvor geordnet haben,
also in der Reihenfolge,
die du hier siehst.
Den Betrag zum Quadrat
dieser Einträge zu nehmen ergibt ein Viertel für den ersten, ebenfalls ein Viertel für den nächsten.
Der Betrag zum Quadrat
von null ist gleich null, daher trägt dieser Eintrag
nicht zur Summe bei. Und schließlich erhalten wir für den letzten 1/2. Die Summe ist also gleich eins, wie es für diesen Vektor
erforderlich ist, um ein Quantenzustandsvektor zu sein. Gerade eben haben wir die Notation
Ket plus und Ket minus verwendet, um auf zwei qubit-Zustandsvektoren zu verweisen, die keine Standardbasisvektoren sind.
Ich möchte kurz auf diesen
Punkt zurückkommen und erklären, wie die Dirac-Notation für beliebige Vektoren verwendet wird und nicht nur für Standardbasisvektoren.
Wie ich bereits erwähnt habe, können wir beliebige Namen
innerhalb eines Bras oder Kets verwenden, um auf einen Vektor zu verweisen.
Kets sind Spaltenvektoren
und Bras sind Zeilenvektoren, genau wie zuvor.
Als Beispiel wird der griechische Buchstabe
Psi sehr häufig innerhalb eines Kets verwendet, um auf einen beliebigen Vektor zu verweisen,
und hier verwenden wir ihn,
um dem Zustandsvektor von vorhin einen Namen zu geben, der keinen speziellen Namen hat.
Wenn wir das tun, hat das Ket Psi
nicht unbedingt eine eigenständige Bedeutung.
Es ist nur der Name eines Vektors, und er steht innerhalb eines Kets, um uns zu verdeutlichen,
dass es sich um einen Spaltenvektor handelt.
Das kann manchmal etwas
verwirrend sein, und es besteht die Möglichkeit von Mehrdeutigkeiten, wenn der Buchstabe Psi mit
einem klassischen Zustand eines
Systems in Verbindung gebracht werden könnte, aber es verursacht im Allgemeinen keine Probleme, und du musst die
Dirac-Notation nicht so verwenden,
wenn du das nicht möchtest. Auch ein Kleinbuchstabe wie
u, v oder w ohne Ket ist eine gute Möglichkeit,
einen Spaltenvektor zu bezeichnen,
oder genauer gesagt,
einen Quantenzustandsvektor.
Du kannst selbst wählen, welche Notation
du verwendest, um dich auszudrücken.
Du musst nur sicherstellen,
dass erstens die Bedeutung dessen, was du
ausdrücken möchtest, für andere klar ist.
Und zweitens, dass du verstehst, was
andere ausdrücken möchten, auch wenn ihre Notationspräferenzen nicht dieselben sind wie deine.
Es gibt eine sehr wichtige Regel für die Verwendung der Dirac-Notation
für beliebige Vektoren, und zwar: wenn du
einen Spaltenvektor hast,
den du beschlossen hast als
Ket Psi zu schreiben, zum Beispiel, oder es könnte ein anderer
Name innerhalb eines Kets sein, dann ist der Zeilenvektor Bra Psi
als die konjugierte Transponierte des Vektors Ket Psi
zu verstehen.
Hier ist das als Gleichung geschrieben, wobei dieses Dagger hier auf die konjugierte Transponierte verweist.
Was das konkret bedeutet, ist:
der Zeilenvektor, den du erhältst, indem du erstens den Vektor transponierst, was bedeutet, dass du
den Vektor auf die Seite kippst und ihn von einer Spalte in eine Zeile umwandelst,
ohne die Einträge tatsächlich zu ändern. Und zweitens, das komplexe Konjugat
jedes Eintrags zu nehmen.
Du kannst diese beiden Operationen tatsächlich
in beliebiger Reihenfolge ausführen – die Transposition und das
eintragsweise komplexe Konjugieren – diese
beiden Operationen kommutieren nämlich.
Für den Vektor in diesem Beispiel gilt also, da wir entschieden haben,
diesen Vektor Ket Psi zu nennen, wird Bra Psi
als dieser Vektor hier verstanden,
wobei wir den Vektor transponiert haben, indem wir Ket null und Ket
eins in Bra null und Bra eins umgewandelt haben, und wir das komplexe
Konjugat jedes Eintrags genommen haben,
weshalb aus eins plus
zwei mal i durch drei hier eins minus zwei
mal i durch drei wird.
So sehen diese Vektoren aus, wenn sie
explizit als Spaltenvektor und Zeilenvektor geschrieben werden.
Beachte übrigens, dass
diese Regel konsistent mit der Notation ist, die wir verwenden, wenn wir klassische Zustände
innerhalb des Bras und des Kets haben.
In diesem Fall sind die Einträge
alle null außer einer Eins, und das komplexe Konjugat
ändert in diesem Fall nichts.
Wir haben nun gesehen, wie Quantenzustände als Vektoren dargestellt werden, aber es ist an diesem
Punkt noch unklar, was die Bedeutung oder die Implikationen sind,
in Bezug darauf, was du
mit dem System in einem Quantenzustand tun kannst oder wie du mit ihm interagieren kannst.
Als erstes müssen wir, um diese Fragen in den Fokus zu bringen,
Messungen besprechen.
Intuitiv gesprochen
bieten Messungen einen Mechanismus, um klassische
Informationen aus Quantensystemen zu extrahieren.
Wenn wir ein System betrachten,
das sich in einem Quantenzustand befindet, sehen wir keinen Quantenzustand, genauso wenig wie wir
probabilistische Zustände sehen,
wir sehen klassische Zustände, und der Begriff der Messung ist das, was die Schnittstelle bereitstellt.
Wenn wir als Menschen etwas über ein Quantensystem wissen möchten, müssen wir es messen, und dabei extrahieren wir klassische Informationen
darüber, in welchem Quantenzustand
sich dieses System befand.
Es gibt verschiedene
Konzepte von Messungen. Der Unterschied liegt wirklich in der Allgemeinheit, und wir beginnen mit dem einfachsten und grundlegendsten,
das typischerweise als
Standardbasismessung bezeichnet wird.
Wir werden das
in den folgenden Lektionen verallgemeinern. In Lektion drei werden wir über sogenannte
projektive Messungen sprechen, und später im
dritten Teil der Serie
werden wir über allgemeine Messungen sprechen, die auch als positive
operatorwertige Maße oder kurz POVMs bezeichnet werden.
Aber für jetzt beschränken wir unsere Aufmerksamkeit auf Standardbasismessungen.
Wenn eine Messung an einem
System durchgeführt wird, gibt es eine Menge
möglicher Ergebnisse dieser Messung, nämlich klassische Ergebnisse,
und im Fall einer
Standardbasismessung sind diese möglichen Ergebnisse
genau die klassischen Zustände des jeweiligen gemessenen Systems.
Jeder dieser klassischen Zustände wird das Ergebnis der Messung mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit sein, und diese Wahrscheinlichkeit ist
der Absolutwert zum Quadrat
des Eintrags, der
jenem klassischen Zustand des Quantenzustandsvektors entspricht,
in dem sich das System unmittelbar vor der Messung befand.
Wir wissen, dass der Absolutwert zum Quadrat einer beliebigen komplexen Zahl eine nicht-negative reelle Zahl ist, und wir wissen aus der Definition
von Quantenzustandsvektoren,
dass die Summe der Absolutwerte
zum Quadrat der Einträge eines Quantenzustandsvektors gleich eins ist.
Das ergibt also Sinn. Jeder klassische Zustand erscheint als Ergebnis der
Messung mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit, und die Wahrscheinlichkeiten summieren sich zu eins.
Hier sind einige Beispiele. Angenommen, wir haben ein
qubit im Plus-Zustand.
Wenn wir dieses qubit bezüglich einer Standardbasis-Messung messen, erhalten wir entweder eine Null oder
eine Eins als Ergebnis.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, eine Null zu erhalten, ist der Absolutwert
zum Quadrat von eins durch Wurzel zwei, was 1/2 ist, und das ist dieselbe
Wahrscheinlichkeit, eine Eins zu erhalten.
Wenn du also einen Plus-Zustand misst, erhältst du ein gleichmäßig zufälliges Bit.
Wenn sich das System in einem Minus-
Zustand anstatt in einem Plus-Zustand befindet, funktioniert das Messen auf
genau die gleiche Weise.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeiten sind wieder jeweils 1/2 für jedes mögliche Ergebnis.
Der einzige Unterschied hier ist, dass das Plus-Zeichen zu einem Minus-Zeichen wurde, aber wenn wir den Absolutwert
nehmen, ändert sich nichts.
Wenn wir diesen qubit-Zustand messen, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, das Ergebnis Null zu erhalten, der Absolutwert zum Quadrat von eins plus zwei mal i
durch drei, was 5/9 ist,
und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, das Ergebnis Eins zu erhalten, ist der Absolutwert zum Quadrat
von minus 2/3, was 4/9 ist.
Und schließlich ergibt das Messen
des Standardbasiszustands ket Null das Ergebnis
Null mit Sicherheit, und ebenso ergibt das Messen des Zustands ket Eins
das Ergebnis Eins mit Sicherheit. Das liegt daran, dass der Absolutwert
zum Quadrat von eins gleich eins ist.
Ähnlich wie im probabilistischen Setting können wir diese Quantenzustände,
ket Null und ket Eins, damit assoziieren, dass sich das System in
diesen klassischen Zuständen befindet,
und dieses Beispiel ist konsistent
mit dieser Interpretation.
Jetzt wird, genau wie im
probabilistischen Setting, wenn wir ein System messen, während
es sich in einem Quantenzustand befindet,
der Zustand sich im Allgemeinen als Ergebnis der durchgeführten
Messung verändern.
Insbesondere, und auch das ist genau wie im
probabilistischen Setting.
Wenn wir ein System messen und das Ergebnis der Messung
der klassische Zustand a ist, dann wird der neue Quantenzustand
des Systems zu ket a.
Für diesen Zustand hier
sehen wir also dieselbe Art
von Verhalten wie im probabilistischen Setting.
Wenn wir messen, erhalten wir mit Wahrscheinlichkeit 5/9 das Ergebnis Null, wobei der Zustand
zu ket Null übergeht,
und mit Wahrscheinlichkeit
4/9 ist das Ergebnis Eins, und der Zustand geht zu ket Eins über.
Manchmal wird dieses Phänomen als Kollaps
des Quantenzustands bezeichnet, und es ist die Art von
Sache, die Menschen
die die Grundlagen
der Quantenmechanik erforschen, nachts wachhält.
Aber aus einer rein
mathematischen Perspektive ist es wirklich recht einfach
und dem, was wir im probabilistischen Fall haben, sehr ähnlich.
Die Quelle der Spannung hier betrifft in gewissem Sinne die grundlegende
Natur der Quantenzustände und was sie repräsentieren
und wie sie sich unterscheiden
von probabilistischen Zuständen. Aber auf mathematischer Ebene ist das vielleicht das, was du erwarten würdest.
Beachte übrigens, dass wenn
du ein zweites Mal misst, du genau
dasselbe Ergebnis wie bei der ersten Messung erhalten würdest.
Es gibt also eine Grenze dafür, wie viel klassische Information aus einem Quantenzustand extrahiert werden kann, und wir werden bald auf diesen Punkt zurückkommen
in einer anderen Lektion. Wir haben über Quantenzustände sowie Messungen gesprochen, speziell Standardbasis-Messungen,
die eine Möglichkeit bieten,
klassische Information aus Quantenzuständen zu extrahieren.
Das verbleibende Thema für
diese Lektion sind Operationen, speziell unitäre Operationen, die beschreiben, wie
Quantenzustände von Systemen
verändert werden können. Da Quantenzustandsvektoren sich von Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektoren unterscheiden, würdest du erwarten, dass die Menge der zulässigen Operationen
auf Quantenzuständen anders ist als das, was wir für
klassische Information haben, und das ist tatsächlich der Fall.
Während Operationen auf probabilistischen Zuständen durch stochastische Matrizen dargestellt werden, werden Operationen auf Quantenzustandsvektoren
durch unitäre Matrizen dargestellt.
Hier ist die Definition von unitären Matrizen.
Eine quadratische Matrix U mit komplexen
Zahleneinträgen ist unitär, wenn sie die Gleichungen erfüllt,
die du hier siehst.
Das Dagger-Symbol steht für
die konjugierte Transponierte, die wir bereits für Vektoren gesehen haben, als wir vor einigen Augenblicken über die Dirac-
Notation gesprochen haben.
Hier führen wir die
konjugierte Transponierte auf einer Matrix statt auf einem Vektor durch, aber es ist im Wesentlichen dasselbe.
Wir transponieren die Matrix, was bedeutet, dass wir
Zeilen und Spalten tauschen, sodass der JK-Eintrag zum KJ-Eintrag wird,
und wir nehmen auch das komplexe
Konjugat jedes Eintrags.
Diese Notation hier
bedeutet die Einheitsmatrix.
Diese beiden Gleichungen hier
sind tatsächlich äquivalent. Wenn du eine hast, dann hast du
automatisch auch die andere.
Beides ist gleichbedeutend damit,
dass U invertierbar ist und die Inverse gleich
dem konjugierten Transponierten ist.
Das gilt übrigens nur für quadratische
Matrizen. Wenn du eine Matrix hast, die nicht quadratisch ist, dann kann eine dieser beiden
Gleichungen wahr sein,
aber dann wird die andere nicht wahr sein.
Hier sprechen wir aber
von quadratischen Matrizen.
Dies ist also die Standarddefinition
für unitäre Matrizen, und sie ist praktisch, weil es einfach zu prüfen ist,
ob eine Matrix unitär ist.
Du multiplizierst die Matrix einfach auf beiden Seiten mit ihrem konjugierten Transponierten und schaust, ob du
die Einheitsmatrix erhältst.
Es gibt eine äquivalente Möglichkeit, unitäre Matrizen zu charakterisieren, nämlich dass eine
quadratische Matrix genau dann unitär ist, wenn sie die euklidische Norm niemals
eines Vektors bei der Multiplikation verändert. Eine N×N-Matrix U ist genau dann unitär, wenn die
euklidische Norm von U mal v
gleich der euklidischen Norm v ist, für jeden n-dimensionalen Spaltenvektor v mit komplexen Einträgen.
Wenn v also ein
Quantenzustandsvektor ist, dann ist U mal v ebenfalls
ein Quantenzustandsvektor, da Quantenzustandsvektoren
einfach die Vektoren sind, deren
euklidische Norm gleich eins ist.
Wir können sogar noch etwas mehr sagen, nämlich dass die unitären Matrizen genau die Matrizen sind, die Quantenzustandsvektoren immer
in Quantenzustandsvektoren umwandeln. Das ist eine ähnliche Situation wie bei stochastischen Matrizen
und Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektoren.
Die stochastischen Matrizen
sind genau die Matrizen, die Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektoren immer in Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektoren umwandeln.
Sobald wir also entschieden haben, dass Operationen durch Matrizen dargestellt werden sollen, was gleichbedeutend damit ist zu sagen, dass Transformationen linear wirken
auf Vektoren, die Zustände repräsentieren, folgen diese Entscheidungen für die Mengen
zulässiger Operationen ganz natürlich, zumindest
in einem mathematischen Sinne.
Schauen wir uns nun einige Beispiele für unitäre qubit-Operationen an.
Wir werden in den folgenden Lektionen noch viele weitere
Beispiele für unitäre Operationen sehen, einschließlich unitärer Operationen in Systemen
mit mehr als zwei klassischen Zuständen. Aber zunächst konzentrieren wir uns nur
auf unitäre qubit-Operationen.
Wir werden diese
bestimmten Beispiele immer wieder sehen, daher lohnt es sich definitiv,
diese Operationen kennenzulernen.
Die erste Sammlung von Beispielen sind die sogenannten Pauli-Operationen.
Das sind die Operationen, die den Pauli-Matrizen entsprechen, die hier gezeigt werden.
Sie sind alle unitär, und du kannst das für jede einzelne gemäß der vorherigen Definition überprüfen.
Diese bestimmten Matrizen
sind zufällig gleich ihren eigenen konjugierten Transponierten, was bedeutet, dass sie
alle hermitesche Matrizen sind.
Um zu prüfen, ob sie
alle unitär sind, muss man in diesem Fall jede einzelne quadrieren und schauen, ob das Ergebnis
die Einheitsmatrix ist.
Die Namen, die du für diese
Matrizen siehst, sind ziemlich Standard, und du wirst sigma x, sigma y und sigma z auch einfach als X, Y und Z bezeichnet sehen.
Beachte jedoch, dass die
Großbuchstaben X, Y und Z auch häufig für andere Zwecke verwendet werden, selbst im Kontext von
Quanteninformation,
aber es sind sehr gebräuchliche
Namen für diese Matrizen.
Die sigma-x- oder X-Operation
wird auch als Bit-Flip oder Nicht-Operation bezeichnet, die wir bereits
im klassischen Kontext gesehen haben.
Und die sigma-z- oder Z-Operation
wird auch als Phasenflip bezeichnet.
Hier kannst du die
Wirkung dieser Operationen auf die Standardbasisvektoren sehen, was ungefähr erklärt,
woher diese Namen stammen.
Es macht durchaus Sinn,
sigma x aufgrund dieser Wirkung hier als Bit-Flip zu bezeichnen.
Es flippt einfach das Bit von
null auf eins oder von eins auf null.
Es macht auch Sinn,
sigma z aufgrund dieser Wirkung hier als Phasenflip zu bezeichnen.
Aber wenn das gerade nicht ganz klar ist,
ist das in Ordnung.
Wir werden auf diese
Operation immer wieder stoßen, und die Bedeutung
davon, ein Minuszeichen vor den Ket-eins-
Basisvektor zu setzen und nicht vor Ket-null,
und warum das ein Phasenflip genannt wird, wird später klarer werden.
Das nächste Beispiel ist
die Hadamard-Operation, die durch
diese Matrix hier dargestellt wird, die fast immer H genannt wird.
Zu prüfen, ob H unitär ist, ist wiederum eine
einfache Berechnung, die du hier sehen kannst, wenn ich aus dem Weg gehe.
Ähnlich wie bei den Pauli-Matrizen ist H sein eigenes konjugiertes Transponiertes.
Wir haben also diese Gleichung hier, und wenn wir die Multiplikation durchführen, erhalten wir die Einheitsmatrix, wie es erforderlich ist.
Das dritte Beispiel ist
eigentlich eine ganze Klasse unitärer Operationen,
bekannt als Phasenoperationen.
Das sind Operationen,
die durch eine beliebige Matrix dargestellt werden, die diese Form hat, die du hier siehst, wobei theta eine beliebige reelle Zahl ist.
Dieser Eintrag hier wird also
immer eine komplexe Zahl auf dem Einheitskreis sein.
Solche Matrizen sind immer unitär, was ich dir zum Verifizieren überlasse.
Diesmal wird das konjugierte Transponierte nicht gleich der ursprünglichen Matrix sein, es sei denn, diese Zahl hier ist zufällig
eine Eins oder eine Minus-Eins,
in welchem Fall wir entweder
die Einheitsmatrix oder sigma z erhalten, die wir
bereits kennengelernt haben.
Genauer gesagt wird das Transponieren
nichts an dieser Matrix ändern, aber das Bilden des komplexen
Konjugats jedes Eintrags ändert diesen Eintrag hier
zu e hoch minus i theta.
Diese zwei speziellen Operationen hier sind besonders wichtige
Beispiele für Phasenoperationen.
Bei der ersten nehmen wir
theta gleich pi durch zwei, und wir erhalten diese Matrix hier.
Diese wird üblicherweise S-Operation oder S gate genannt,
wenn wir über circuits sprechen, was wir in dieser Lektion nicht behandeln werden,
aber das ist ein wichtiges
Thema, das bald folgen wird.
Die zweite ist diese Operation. Es ist eine T-Operation oder ein T gate.
Und bei dieser ist theta
gleich pi durch vier. Wenn wir also die Exponentialfunktion berechnen, erhalten wir diesen Wert hier, nämlich eins plus i durch
die Quadratwurzel aus zwei.
Hier sind nur ein paar kurze Beispiele, um einige dieser
Operationen in Aktion zu sehen.
Hier ist die Wirkung der
Hadamard-Operation auf Ket null und Ket eins.
Wenn wir die
Matrix-Vektor-Multiplikation durchführen, sehen wir, dass wir den Plus-Zustand und den
Minus-Zustand erhalten, jeweils entsprechend.
Wenn wir die Hadamard-Operation auf den Plus-Zustand und den
Minus-Zustand anwenden, bekommen wir andererseits Ket null und Ket eins zurück.
Wenn wir die Dinge also etwas aufräumen, können wir die Wirkung klarer sehen.
Die Hadamard-Operation
transformiert hin und her zwischen dem Null-Zustand und dem Plus-Zustand sowie zwischen dem Eins-Zustand
und dem Minus-Zustand.
Bezüglich dieser zwei Gleichungen hier ist zu beachten, dass uns das eine einfache Möglichkeit gibt, den Unterschied zwischen einem Plus-Zustand und einem Minus-Zustand zu erkennen.
Wie wir früher in der Lektion gesehen haben, wenn wir einen Plus-Zustand
und einen Minus-Zustand bezüglich der
Standardbasis-Messung messen,
erhalten wir in beiden Fällen ein gleichmäßig zufälliges Bit, was uns nicht hilft,
den Unterschied zu erkennen.
Aber wenn wir eine Hadamard-Operation durchführen
und dann messen, sehen wir eine null, wenn der
ursprüngliche Zustand ein Plus-Zustand war,
und eine eins, wenn der ursprüngliche
Zustand ein Minus-Zustand war.
Diese zwei Zustände sind also tatsächlich verschieden, und sie können
durch die Methode, die ich gerade beschrieben habe, perfekt unterschieden werden,
nämlich zuerst eine
Hadamard-Operation durchzuführen und dann zu messen.
Zurück zum Beispiel eines
qubit-Zustands, den wir vorher gesehen haben und der nicht besonders speziell ist: wir können sehen, was die Hadamard-Operation
mit dem Zustand macht,
indem wir in die Formen umwandeln,
die du hier siehst, und die Multiplikation durchführen.
Und hier ist das Ergebnis,
das wir bei Bedarf zurück in die Dirac-Notation umwandeln können,
und das ist eine Möglichkeit, diese
Art von Wirkungen zu berechnen.
Hier ist ein weiteres Beispiel, das zeigt, dass du nicht immer
explizit in eine Matrix-Vektor-Form umwandeln musst.
Du kannst diese
Berechnungen auch direkt mit der Dirac-Notation durchführen.
Dieses Beispiel betrifft die T-Operation, und hier ist sie
als Referenz.
Diese Operation hat diese Wirkung hier auf Standardbasis-Zustände.
Und wenn wir die
Wirkung der T-Operation auf einen Plus-Zustand berechnen möchten, können wir zum Beispiel damit beginnen, die
Definition des Plus-Zustands zu expandieren,
und dann Linearität verwenden,
um das Ergebnis auszudrücken, wie du es hier siehst.
Wir können nun einfach
diese Ausdrücke hier oben einsetzen, ein bisschen
Vereinfachung beim zweiten Term vornehmen, und wir erhalten das Ergebnis.
Falls wir aus irgendeinem Grund eine Hadamard-Operation
auf das Ergebnis anwenden möchten, können wir etwas Ähnliches tun.
Zuerst setzen wir den Ausdruck für T, der auf den Plus-Zustand wirkt, ein und verwenden Linearität wie zuvor.
Und wenn wir nun die
Ausdrücke einsetzen, die wir bereits für die Hadamard-Operation
haben, die auf Ket null und Ket eins wirkt,
erhalten wir das. Und jetzt können wir den
Plus-Zustand und den Minus-Zustand expandieren, um diesen Ausdruck hier zu erhalten,
den wir einfach durch Addition vereinfachen können, und hier ist das endgültige Ergebnis.
An diesem Beispiel ist nichts besonders
Spezielles. Es soll nur
diese alternative, aber gleichwertige Methode
zur Berechnung der Wirkungen veranschaulichen
dieser Operationen. Du kannst die Methode verwenden,
die in der jeweiligen Situation praktischer ist.
Ein letzter Punkt zu
unitären Operationen ist, dass Kompositionen unitärer
Operationen durch Matrixmultiplikation dargestellt werden,
genau wie im probabilistischen Fall, d.h. du kannst die Wirkung einer Folge unitärer Operationen berechnen,
indem du einfach
die Matrizen multiplizierst. Und was du erhältst, ist
eine einzelne unitäre Matrix, die die kombinierte Wirkung darstellt
der Folge von Operationen.
Genau wie bei stochastischen Matrizen sind die unitären Matrizen
unter Multiplikation abgeschlossen, sodass du immer eine unitäre Matrix erhältst,
wenn du unitäre Operationen komponierst.
Du musst darauf achten,
dass du die Matrizen in der richtigen Reihenfolge multiplizierst.
Aber die Funktionsweise ist genau wie bei
stochastischen Operationen, wo die Matrix für die
erste Operation, die du durchführst,
immer auf der rechten Seite
des Matrixprodukts erscheint, und die letzte auf
der linken Seite.
Genau wie zuvor ist die Reihenfolge also umgekehrt, in dem Sinne, dass du von rechts nach links statt von links nach rechts komponierst.
Hier ist ein interessantes Beispiel, das zu einer Operation führt, die als Quadratwurzel der Nicht-Operation bekannt ist.
Angenommen, wir wenden zuerst
eine Hadamard-Operation an, gefolgt von einer S-Operation, gefolgt von einer weiteren Hadamard-Operation.
Die kombinierte Wirkung
dieser drei Operationen wird durch dieses Produkt beschrieben.
Hier ist die erste Hadamard-Operation, hier ist die S-Operation, und hier ist die zweite Hadamard-Operation.
Wenn wir die Matrixmultiplikation durchführen, die hier nicht explizit gezeigt wird, aber du kannst das selbst machen, wenn du möchtest,
ist das Ergebnis diese Matrix hier. Es ist eine unitäre Matrix, und wir können das entweder direkt überprüfen
oder wir können darauf vertrauen, dass die unitären Matrizen
unter Multiplikation abgeschlossen sind.
Sie muss unitär sein, weil diese drei Matrizen unitär sind, wie wir bereits gesehen haben.
Wir haben hier keinen bestimmten
Quantenzustandsvektor im Sinn.
Wir können uns vorstellen, diese Sequenz von Operationen auf einen beliebigen Quantenzustandsvektor anzuwenden, und diese Matrix beschreibt die Wirkung.
Der Grund, warum diese kombinierte Operation, also die durch diese Matrix hier beschriebene, als „square root of not"-Operation bezeichnet wird,
ist, dass wir durch zweimalige Anwendung eine Not-Operation erhalten, oder anders gesagt, eine
Sigma-x- oder X-Operation.
Die zweimalige Anwendung der Operation
wird durch das Quadrieren der Matrix oder
das Multiplizieren mit sich selbst dargestellt.
Und wenn du das machst, wirst du sehen, dass das Ergebnis
die Pauli-X-Matrix ist.
Das ist irgendwie merkwürdig, und es gibt dir einen kleinen Hinweis, dass du mit Quanteninformation einige interessante Dinge tun kannst, die du mit
klassischer Information nicht tun kannst.
Es gibt keine klassische Operation, also eine, die durch eine stochastische Matrix dargestellt wird, die uns eine Not-Operation liefert,
wenn wir sie zweimal anwenden.
Es ist also ein schönes Beispiel, das zeigt, dass sich Quantenoperationen
sehr anders verhalten als klassische Operationen.
Und das war Lektion eins. In dieser Lektion haben wir besprochen, wie Quanteninformation für einzelne Systeme in Isolation funktioniert,
und in der nächsten Lektion werden wir darüber sprechen, wie
Quanteninformation für mehrere Systeme funktioniert.
Danke fürs Zuschauen. Wenn du Fragen hast, kannst du sie gerne im
Kommentarbereich unten hinterlassen.